this is self-isolation in st. Petersburg
unlike Moscow which unexpectedly lifted
lockdown earlier this week the city's
only due to ease restrictions on Monday
but some Petersburg has never been like
Moscow always windier a little colder
and generally a lot more relaxed no
surprise that it's only here there's an
actual physical tribute to the city's
lost health workers tacked on to a
construction site
Irina Merce lover put up the first nine
photographs at the end of April and she
keeps adding more over here we have the
health department that's why the wall is
opposite down it is the very
governmental structure responsible for
the health and lives of these very
people actually for the health of all
the people in this city and I want them
to see this photos from their windows
every day some petersburg's kovat
response was less well managed than
Moscow's fewer beds longer ambulance
queues whole hospitals locked down the
virus rife inside
we found it hard to find health workers
who speak openly it's quite likely that
I'll stir up a hornet's nest and people
will say yes we have bad PPE we don't
have enough doctors we like the staff
yes we don't get the money we deserve
for this work but it's not right to talk
about it you should just keep silence
and get on with your work
Leah Vova Bach who runs one of the
city's private ambulance services says
medical personnel are preparing for a
second wave almost all the hospitals in
the city of fall probably the number of
patients who have kovat is not so big in
some petersburg but there are many cases
and they're mentioned in the official
data of covert like pneumonias which in
most cases are caused by the Koval
infection we follow one of his
ambulances - a case
turns out not to be covert and the staff
are all fairly relaxed as is everyone
else on a day this in Petersburg
governor pols residents online about
which restrictions they want lifted
first starting with children's
playgrounds they're already crawling
with people this pandemic isn't over
with half a million cases it isn't
anywhere near over
President Putin doesn't want this
lockdown ended just because of the
economy for the sake of their small
business owners of Moscow and st.
Petersburg it's because of this vote a
vote on changing the Constitution and
zeroing the presidential term count
president Putin's approval ratings have
taken a massive covert related hit but
with Russia day this Friday and the
Victory Day Parade the week after next
summer Sun and pageantry are a barefaced
pitch to win them back dynamic they Sky
News sent Petersburg
[Music]